hello everyone and welcome back to big
moo it's a big mood
[Music]
today we're gonna play another game
we're gonna play would you rather
because you guys seem to enjoy that and
we are no winners in this game
there's no there's absolutely no winners
in this game
um who do we have here today with us
obviously me
jess hi it's gina
sorry she almost looks at me first i'm
just like her rock was open
and i guess this is tiff you guess i
guess
i guess i i finally get to speak
like we silence her yeah
okay so should we just jump in do you
guys want the sex
ones or do you guys want like just
random all of them baby hit me those
next ones mix them up mix them up
okay we'll mix them up we have this
thing we need to
change the set decor because you keep
it'll change on the next one this is the
second time today that i'm just breaking
[ __ ] on this set man yeah
yeah you're knocking everything off the
walls angry issues
all right so let's just jump in
hopefully this will make sense because i
think i wrote this one myself
oh boy some of these i got off the
internet and some of them i was like
trying to make up on my own but okay
gonna be all cute
yeah would you rather you always get
paid to have sex with gross people only
so your whole sex life
a lot whatever okay enough for it to be
worth it okay but that's your only sex
it's
just gross people but whenever i want it
or is it like i have to have sex once a
day or something no it's just like
they're gonna pay for it you can take
the job or not but that your
your only sexual experience is that
you're getting paid for it and they're
gross
okay okay or you always have to pay
someone else that you want to have sex
with
hmm i always wanted to okay if you want
to have sex with a guy you're actually
attracted to and not a gross person you
have to pay them okay
i pay them i'd pay them same i would pay
so so you would never have sex
unless you get expensive but i kind of
feel like a baller
like yeah yeah give me your dick now
give it to me also boss me around the
hell
or hear me out set my price
only [ __ ] one ugly dude forever
yeah mary and one time just one time but
then you can't have any other sex
oh [ __ ] the only way you can have sex is
if someone gross pays you to have sex
marry an ugly gross dude that i love
this isn't mary [ __ ] hill
i like dude i don't know i've i've been
there i've had sex with guys that i was
not
attracted to at all and i'm just not
really trying to do that again so
i just i can't masturbate i'd rather pay
i'm a sapiosexual so i feel like if they
had enough stimulating conversation
any gross dude could be hot and i could
like
have it happen gina's not buying it dick
cheese
i'd still still pay dirty they're not
dirty
well they're just like you're just not
attracted like that's why they're paying
you
like what's his name from uh 30 day
fiance the no neck dude
we're kind
okay that's something oh something just
unlocked in my brain
sorry that was a totally different time
of mine yeah i i pay i pay
i get paid too i'm trying to think about
it
i'm trying to think about it i'm like if
i never had to work because they're
paying for you haven't had sex with
someone you like in a long time
that's true that is okay way to point
that out
i haven't had sex since like august of
2020 august i think i actually wrote it
in my notes i think it was like august
15th because i wanted
i wanted a tally to see how long it's
been august 15 2020
was the last time i had a dick in me
that's been a while
um and so at this point now i'm just
like yeah you're like well i wouldn't
have to work i guess i guess i could
just
you know i'm already not having sex i'm
not having sex with them why don't they
just pay me for it um
but also i could do that now when i
don't yeah
so i guess i'm probably not
realistically
that down yeah plus i feel like the
even the control aspect of it like i
don't like the
the power dynamic there yeah because
then you they like kind of make you
feel whatever they're obligated to do
whatever they want yeah no i think i
would definitely
rather choose to have zero sex and zero
money
versus yes having to have gross sex
more money yeah agree yeah but that's
interesting i wonder if guys would
give the same answer to him i cheat the
system how i'm gonna pay the dude to
have like the hot dude have sex with me
start a relationship whatever i pay him
he's gonna spend it back on me anyway
like that it's like a loophole yeah okay
there you go there you go can i get a
hot dude on top of that yeah
because he won't be able to help but
fall in love with you yeah exactly i
guess you broke my system
so you win
all right people in the comments that we
play would you rather wrong by the way
how are you supposed to play i don't
know but yeah maybe we just
they said i think it's because they
don't like that we're like explaining
ourselves out of [ __ ]
or whatever but yeah we're just trying
to explain
yeah it's a discussion it's like um it's
more than just a
no two cheese or french fries yeah you
know it's like a whole it makes you
think
right yeah if you don't like it explode
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yourself
would you rather be able to talk to
animals
oh like eliza elizabeth thornberry what
liza
the [ __ ] thornberries who's that
brother
is that the cartoon johnny yeah yeah
from nickelodeon oh my god that's so old
well these kids aren't going to know
what that [ __ ] is i think i'm aged
up out of that yeah i don't know who the
[ __ ] that is
oh my god you're so young
you're so old you're so young now yes
i'm into mid-life crisis mode where i go
young again
yeah true yeah we see that a lot with me
following my teenage daughters
um okay so would you rather be able to
talk to animals or
know the origin and purpose of life the
[ __ ]
animals animals for sure really
yeah i don't care i'm here already
biggest questions in the world wait wait
we're here first so
wait then you just worded it wrong
origin and purpose of life like the
origin of life
you get to know the org
and the meaning of life okay like is
there a god
why are we here is it [ __ ] aliens
there's all these guys
animals animals i got [ __ ] to say all
they do is lick ass and [ __ ] sleep
here's my here's my debate one that's
way too much responsibility
why because i have to know all the
answers and everyone's gonna come
up to me like you don't gotta tell
anyone you know well i don't wanna know
if i can't tell anyone
true that's true that's her problem
true true it's a good choice when i tell
someone how they're not going to believe
me i'm going to be like well someone
came down would you rather talk to
animals or
dancers i chose this over and i wish i
chose the animals
start an army of animals what the [ __ ]
are the animals going to tell you
oh they know the secrets of them no
they don't they're animals they know
what's
here no haven't you ever seen ant-man i
would try to like
i would talk to them and like control
them with my minds
no they'll talk to you like with their
little mouse their little dog mouths and
their little cats
so cute so [ __ ] cute yeah and then
you get to find out all these secrets
because imagine like having pets like
imagine me being yeah but i get to see
what's going on in your house
oh maddie's riding me out she's like i
saw her [ __ ] bend over
scratch your [ __ ] like all this [ __ ]
oh my god i can have animal spies
yeah exactly exactly you take your cat
with you put them in the room with the
people you think are talking [ __ ] about
you yeah
oh they'll be sick yeah animals that
makes sense for like
fun but i think i'd still rather want to
know the origin and purpose of life
meh for what though like what are you
gonna do what are you gonna
um a reason to live
what if the answer was there is no
person then i'd be like okay then i can
go do crazy [ __ ]
then now i'm free to go be evil and do
whatever
the [ __ ] i don't know just anything i
have a conscience now
i have a conscience i'm concerned if
there's no purpose of life
none of us none of our souls even really
exist like souls are fake like all that
then i'm like well who cares
i don't know about any of it because it
feels real so like even if i know that
it's all silly i still don't think i
would want to kill someone or hurt
anyone because i still feel the bad
people
or like what if we find out that we're
in the matrix for example like a
simulation
then i would [ __ ] i'd [ __ ] with the
matrix like i'd be doing all kinds of
crazy [ __ ]
okay you can do that now okay okay hear
me i'm not really not really
out here okay okay how sick would it be
right
if you like go on a date with a dude and
you're like you want to see something
[ __ ] cool
hey eagle come here and he just lands on
you and then
panty dropper and then it starts talking
yeah like you don't do that
we don't need to do anything for a man
to drop their panties
yeah you show a titty okay fine okay
here hear me out here hear me out okay
hear me out
i can make so much money off of this you
could be able to talk to you you really
could
yeah that's i should start a cult yeah
but you know they have those friends
you have pet psychics that you know
people could choose whether to believe
it's real or not
so like even if you could legit talk to
animals
no one's gonna believe you prove it to
them and be like
hey you stupid bird come here and then
[ __ ] in their mouth directly there he
goes
like if you could tell the animals like
so much exactly
the exact same time that was perfect
timing like if you could tell the
example some
very exact things to do or like take
even audience [ __ ] participation
[ __ ] like how can how can you not prove
that you're communicating with that
animal
exactly like if i'm like if you know if
i'm not training that like i don't know
what the audience is going to ask animal
to do
but then they don't think about it too
you'd be like pet uh what's the same ace
ventura pet detective
where your entire apartment is filled
with animals because now that you can
speak to them they're gonna be like
oh my god you couldn't understand me
feed me oh [ __ ] though
like ghosts yeah exactly oh my god
you're gonna be an animal magnet
everywhere you go there's gonna be like
57
birds like all the dogs and cats
you know what i always like though is
you know how squirrels don't interrupt
each other
as like common knowledge right as if we
understand
squirrel hierarchy i hear them talking
every day and i'm like what are they
[ __ ] saying because they don't
interrupt like why don't you like
personal observation no they don't
interrupt each other
sounded like nikki discovered this but
thank
did you figure that out i'm pretty sure
google told me it once
but maybe not i don't remember now
you're one of those
really uh interesting kids when you're a
kid i'm on the spectrum
okay she's autistic and it makes a lot
more sense these days go bye
wait so what were you saying that they
don't interrupt you no so one will be
like
pee pee pee pee deep they sound like
that they sound like birds and then they
wait
and listen and then yeah and then the
other one goes
so do you think they're actually talking
yeah because they get pissed too like it
looks like one's like scolding another
one
like their tail flickers like
i just want to know i'm like a neighbor
that's like listening to the gossip but
i don't know what they're saying dude
imagine they're like some
[ __ ] aliens that they're like yeah
exactly
i do like wait i know i've seen this
that was rick and morty huh was it
squirrels
yeah it was squirrels don't [ __ ] with
squirrels
there we go damn i'm still trying to
like figure out why the animal one is
cooler than the other one but you guys
are just on your own level
so we're cat ladies so yeah and maybe
dog people don't understand
probably not animal army all day that's
what i'm talking about
the simple thing is if you have a pet
you can just ask them like dude what the
[ __ ] is your problem if they won't shut
up because my cat never shuts up yeah or
and i could tell my cat to stop peeing
on my couch because he's doing it to
protect me
but i'm like i don't need your
protection i don't need it i wish i
could tell my cat to stop [ __ ] on my
couch i'm like please can you please
it's a brand new couch it does not have
cats
[ __ ] on your furniture and now i can
finally like convey my love to my cat so
he understands
i think he knows good uh i don't think
they do
no they do like happy to have a
professional like my cat they look you
in your eyeballs and they know your soul
they really do sure
all right i guess i don't really know
how to talk to that cat because he
already knows me but the other one that
pees
he's a lost he's not getting it
all right let's go with another sexual
one
we're gonna whiplash it more sexual than
talking about animals we're gonna
whiplash
no no the first one was actual i'm
whiplashing it back to the
back to the beginning would you rather
would you rather drink a full glass of
your partner's pee
some people say oh i guess it is for
some people pay for that or
you can only drink his [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] for three days
for three days you could drink one glass
full of your partner's pee
or the same amount of days it's just the
[ __ ] that comes out of him oh so three
three days worth of nuts or you drink
one full glass of urine come
i love [ __ ] ew ew okay so
once i come and then you said it yeah
but if i given the choice
i would rather drink a regular amount of
[ __ ] than a glass three days
of urine yeah yeah that's all you get to
eat for three days so you're gonna have
a little tummy
so no food no food [ __ ] someone's gonna
cook that [ __ ] what
i love i love
[Applause]
easy peasy that's a [ __ ] tuesday for
me let's go no food
come only three days i barely eat as it
is yeah that's true
yeah ellie she's getting a whole ass
stomach ache for me i'm choosing pee
and my man's gonna be happy that's true
good fine i can't do it i can't have
stomach aches for three days
i can't do it i don't think i'd get a
stomachache i just get really hangry
like i get pretty cranky when i'm hungry
yeah um can i chill the urine sure
you could put some ice in there you
could put this oh can we can i put it in
my ice cream maker
you want to make it make it look like
the ice cream same question same
question for the
same question for the [ __ ] same question
that was the filipino dessert with the
um
condensed milk on the top oh shaved ice
was condensed milk yeah yeah
that sounds pretty bomb if you think
about it three days have come that means
we're banging a lot so this is a win-win
situation yeah
because that doesn't mean you're
necessarily paying you could just be in
a cup
that's fine too he's just coming ew
that's gross i want to straight from the
spout
[Applause]
on top
[Music]
[Music]
we're both your end they're both nuts i
know what else come gives me such a
stomach
ache i mean am i alone in this stomach i
don't know
you have a sensitive stomach i do have
this i have acid reflux and i think
yeah it's just not good oh imagine like
it's like
i like burp acidic bubbles and i i just
can't handle it
yeah and if you had to survive in the
world you would have to drink
some pea at some point you get water huh
do you get water
with these sure because you need water
to live
yeah thank you you know what it's like
for me
you know how you hate saliva you're like
just disgusting
that's what nut is for me like oh like i
just get
really grossed out to have it in my
mouth i can have it anywhere else
especially if the guy's diet hasn't been
very good for like a week you know they
eat real shitty then their [ __ ] gets like
real rank also guys have different guys
have different viscosities have come
and so i've smelled some fishy come
before oh that's not
is that healthy probably not steve's is
not that thick so i feel like it go down
really easy
i feel like this is too much information
you know we know too much of us
texting them afterwards hey i heard you
have watery [ __ ]
you got that weak ass cup it's not
watery but you know some guys have like
it's like a booger thick like yeah it
just it doesn't never shoots out it's
just that i can't know
oh god i've seen that
it's like ranch yeah it's dressing a
loogie
all the guys listening they're like oh
man yeah sorry i'm not trying to shame
your [ __ ]
i just all come here i've gotten this
equally valuable
dudes yeah i'll take the urine thank you
chilled urine so we could do we don't
have to do like good food no no not
sludge
i don't know that might make it easier
to go down yeah see because i'm
protecting you
i like a full [ __ ] glass of ice with
my dreams yeah
i'm down for that super chill yeah you
put it in an ice cream maker it turns
into slush
good to go baby it's like i just want to
like [ __ ] down it that's it
it's just cold so it takes out all the
urine yeah
my stomach hurts honestly i take both of
those over saliva though
yeah we get it we know it's getting a
shot
of saliva that's pretty mouths are
disgusting too disgusting
okay would you rather
give up all drinks except for water
so you can only drink water no alcohol
no nothing just water that's what i do
already
yeah same forever yeah just water
forever okay
or you can never eat junk food ever
again
never eat junk food you don't like junk
food no
wait so you like other beverages more
excess of carbs too
like just tons of bread and pasta yeah
that's kind of junky i can just eat the
same thing over and over again forever
oh no whoa i have to do the water one
way like because one oh
you picked a water one yes because i
like junk food and second of all
i i might be healthy for once in my life
yeah you know like i never drink alcohol
again
[Laughter]
i've gone on really restrictive diets
before but i couldn't do them without
coffee
um coffee is like what really [ __ ]
makes it hard for me
yeah dude i'd totally go with them but
then you could take just caffeine pills
nah not the same and drink to journal
and water
my coffee have you tried drinking hot
water
yes it works they do that a lot in asia
it's actually really comforting i never
i thought it was weird until i started
doing i did it for a cleanse once yeah
not my favorite yeah it's like hot water
with lemon
yeah it's supposed to like really help
your digestive system get started mm-hmm
like you could do it and coffee
essentially but i just i i don't
um but coffee does uh stain your teeth
so you know if you're looking for that
nice ass smile
well i'm not sure canda does anything
about coffee stains but they will
fix your effed up teeth candid is a
clear comfortable
removable and practically invisible
aligner to help straighten your teeth
they're here to help straighten your
teeth so that you can fall in love with
your smile
we all know people that got brace face i
luckily
have perfect teeth so i never had to
have them but i watched a lot of myself
girl flesh i watched a lot of my friends
uh suffer with
brace face yeah and uh i i feel really
bad that they missed i had the rubber
bands that went across yeah
headgear yeah what you had headgear
big old nerd over here with the headgear
you kids don't realize how easy you have
it now
getting these clear plastic aligners
yeah um
but yeah so candid with candid your
treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored and remotely
uh monitored by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you'll
have the same quality of care you get
from an
in-off office orthodontist from the
comfort and convenience of your own home
i mean everything is done from home now
it makes it so much easier
than driving across town every time and
while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists legit orthodontists and
you have the same one from the start to
finish of your plan
so you're not getting shuffled around to
a bunch of different doctors or anything
the average candid treatment is just six
months you start to see results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today right now you could
save 75
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use our code mood that's candid
co
dot com slash mood with the code mood
take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75
on your starter kit that's
dot candidco.com slash mood with the
code mood
and while you're in the process of your
glow up with your straight ass teeth
hell yeah why not get a new wardrobe but
not spend a whole bunch of money on i
like that i like it too
curtsy is an app that i've been using
they also sponsor the show they gave us
a little gift card and i
am addicted yes that was a good move um
so it's a thrifting app
which means you can i mean it's second
hand but there's so many options and so
many filters you can put on there i
decided to
only shop for brands that i would
normally
not pay full price on like anthropology
for example is one of my favorite brands
there's some lululemon stuff that's
super expensive but it lasts really well
so secondhand
yes and you can search for it to be
brand new
with tags even so a lot of the pieces
that i got i got a whole
whole new wardrobe from like from
anthropology nice ass stores
reformation um for just a fraction of
the cost it was like a hundred bucks for
like a whole big ass wardrobe
and a lot of them were still brand new
or new with tags
so no one had ever worn them i know i
was like these girls just went shopping
never used it and now they're selling it
to me
this is great dude sometimes you know i
don't know if they work in retail
or wholesale yeah i'm like how do they
get this so maybe they just like buy a
bunch of stuff you know sometimes yeah
i'm like are they sugar sugar daddies
like why do they have so much
unused like nice clothes sometimes i've
bought stuff and then um i gained too
much weight and then it didn't fit
anymore and then i kept it for a while
with the tag on
like thinking you're gonna lose weight
and i was like yo this makes me sad
i'm just gonna sell it yeah um yeah and
the app has all my favorite brands you
can search by brand it's awesome
selling clothes is actually such a pain
in the ass normally which is why my
closet
is always overflowing but curtsy
actually makes the selling process
really easy you can get their shipping
kit for free you just like order their
shipping kit
they send you the bags also jess likes
to get designer stuff on there yes i got
coach stuff on there and they check for
the authenticity of it
if it's over a certain dollar amount
they'll send it to their warehouse and
make sure that someone's not selling
you some fake [ __ ] so yeah i like that
it's dope so if you want a sustainable
way to get brandy urban champion
and lulu delivered directly to your door
download curtsy today and enter promo
code mood
for 15 off your first order search for
curtsy in the app store spelled
c-u-r-t-s-y
and enter promo code mood for 15 off
your first order
download the curtsy app and enter promo
code mood
[Music]
did we i don't think we answer fully
answered the question on the water or
the
did we say yeah and you haven't no yeah
i mean i was saying that for sure the
water
because that's easy rather have junk
food
yeah i mean because i'm already drinking
like 90
of anything that i drink is water yeah
there's like very few like right now i'm
drinking
chico but that's like rare like i almost
never drink anything that's not water so
for me that one's the water
yes sparkling water that's the water
mineral water yeah that counts yeah
oh it does yeah oh then [ __ ] yeah like
oh you never
drink alcohol again you'll never drink
coffee i mean i'll never drink a
smoothie again
i already gave up coffee i haven't drink
you'll never drink horchata
oh that's hard but i haven't drank
coffee since november
yeah i gave up coffee and alcohol well
alcohol kind of not really like for the
most part
um but yeah i mean it would still be
easy for me yeah
i wouldn't really struggle and then junk
food i actually don't even eat that much
junk food either but if i had to pick
one
from the two then i would just be
watching like i've mostly only seen you
eat junk food so i guess you eat really
healthy when i'm not around you then
yeah i almost because i i'm like when
we're together we always eat junk food
yeah because we're filming those or yeah
i almost never touch hot cheetos anymore
you really but you're
talking it gives me no i actually can't
dude i'm not mexican anymore
i can't handle spicy [ __ ] anymore like
one cheeto
will give me heartburn yeah yeah that
kind of does that to me now i think
we're getting
old yeah so i can't do spicy things at
all like i can't even i see takis all
the time i can't [ __ ] eat takis
anymore you burned a hole in your gut
yeah i ate too much even [ __ ] tahini
sometimes
oh really i want to talk about it wow
that's probably what [ __ ] up your
stomach because you're just eating salt
straight up i was eating a [ __ ] tonight
lemons all the time
just all acid yeah dude now i can't do
it now i have to be healthy and just
stay away from that stuff did you answer
no
so i was trying to think about it and
i'm like um
i know i enjoy junk food more than i
enjoy different types of liquids but i
think
if i was going to choose from my
lifetime i would rather get rid of the
junk food and have access to coffee and
alcohol and
smoothies and juices and all that stuff
because it would be better for me in the
long run my vices are all drinks i think
yeah my advices are the junk food that's
why i want to get rid of the junk food
i would have to make a better choice for
myself yeah it'll be easy for me because
i
rarely drink anyways yeah so i'm good so
we you we each either leaned to the left
or the right
i really i rarely drink too but i'm like
yeah i need the coffee and all the other
good
mm-hmm the wonders of the world i've
been eating so much junk food over
the pandemic though i think i'm just so
disgusted by it and disgusted by myself
that's why i'm like oh god i need
it's time to clean it up detox clean up
my act
get back in the gym i'll finally have
clear pee for once in my life oh my gosh
for once what have you been doing to get
that clear p drinking water
more water you should have some bright
yellow pea from taking b
vitamins that too i don't have clear pea
because i do drink a lot of vitamins or
take a lot of vitamins
so i pretty much never have clear pee
but i drink like
a whole thing of water every hour you
pee a lot i pee every hour i pee a lot
oh [ __ ]
and it's not clear um well half the day
it's not like when i take my vitamins it
still takes a few peas to
get it to be clear again you know
someone's getting turned on by this
yeah you know too much like there's like
drinking a cup of jess's pee and it's
like bright yellow
it's great mine has this consistency of
maple syrup
[Applause]
can you imagine trying to pee out maple
syrup oh god right
i'm good move on all right
would you rather
stop being able to kiss your partner
forever
you can never kiss your mate ever again
or you'll never get oral sex again
oh receive it i guess i could give up
oral sex i can give it worse
give up oral sex yeah yeah that just
means you guys suck at oral sex
no he's good but the romance from the
kissing
is like that's so much more intimate
yeah then
and i can still [ __ ] i guarantee guys
would
always choose to stop kissing and always
choose to continue to get [ __ ]
that's steve
i think that's what he's 100 no he likes
them it's just the same thing like
we talk about he's a [ __ ] simple
that's what he is
romantic okay he's a [ __ ] symptom he
likes to look at my eyes and then kiss
me no i like that i like that answer and
i like to know that a man like that
exists
because i don't think there's very many
oh i want to see these comments now men
which one
which one which one are you gonna are
you really gonna give up blow jobs
you're really gonna do it they will you
don't have the romance not until they
find that girl
yeah the one actually i wonder what kind
of guy casey would definitely not give
up blow jobs
guarantee it i mean yeah because
he yeah he really likes them he doesn't
really get them that like
crazy often like we really kiss your
choices we kiss way more often so i'm
like
i don't know he seems more excited by
the kissing you think
uh no he really likes he really likes
him
yeah i'm learning so much about y'all's
husbands i give a really good head gina
it's not even that he likes blow jobs is
that i give really good health oh my
sister i don't know
i'm not like those other girls with your
dentures yeah with my [ __ ]
aligners yeah you can't feel the
dude i was watching this um youtube
video i can't remember what it was but
oh i think it was on that that youtube
channel called abba and preach
oh yeah yeah that one that because i
went down the rabbit hole i love their
channel
yeah they were watching a video of like
um i think a jubilee video where the
oh yeah the guy was supposed where the
girl asked the guy
like would how would you rate my blow
jobs on a scale of one to ten and then
he was like oh i'm calling it he's gonna
give her an eight and then the guy goes
um i would say an eight and then they
were just [ __ ] cracking up because
like guys will never
tell you when your blow jobs are not
good yeah but even if they are really
good they're not gonna give you a ten
because they still want you to try
harder
that's so true so i feel like you should
go home and ask your husband like what
number they would give you and test them
to see like are they going to give you
that same answer of an eight
because no what do you think steve would
give you he always rates me 10 out of 10
for everything oh
yeah he has you on a pedestal yeah he
does and he's not afraid to tell me
every day how much
he puts me there yeah it's very sweet i
feel very very loved
yeah that's not a flex at all it's just
i'm that's him that's
that's who steve is yeah that's adorable
sweet thing
that's very sweet what else do we have
here
okay we could break it down bring it all
down bring it on bring it down something
serious
would you rather be transported
to relive a difficult moment in your
past no transported
transported to relive that difficult
moment in your past
very very terrible difficult one or
be told right now and know exactly
what's going to happen a difficult
moment that's going to happen to you
in the future future i rather hear the
past
i've already been through it i've been
through it i know how to get through it
again
i don't i don't want to know something
that hasn't happened yet because i'm
going to try to change it or some [ __ ]
and then it's just it's going to be
worse taking up all of your life anxiety
because because yeah because it could be
something like the death of someone
close to you
and then like now you're forever
thinking about that yeah i'd rather
go i hate going back to pass because it
takes so long to heal
from past traumas that like if you're
already healed from it though going back
is like that exposure therapy kind of
thing
yeah maybe it'll that would be
definitely better than
a future thing that hasn't happened yet
that i haven't even gotten a chance to
heal from
yeah i want to say future because i mean
i've been through the past [ __ ] already
got through it i don't need to do it
again and i want to know the future
because i'm a very
i i like to know information as much as
possible so i can prepare for it
so i'd rather be able to prepare and
kind of what try to ready myself as much
as i could
like the let down or the sadness right
the shock won't be so strong
right and then i feel like if i knew
like it's a passing of a loved one
it would encourage me even more to spend
even more time with them
and tell them that i love them until
everything like i want to prepare for
that but if you didn't know what it was
who it was yeah you're just like you're
gonna have someone that's lost or
something i mean yeah no [ __ ]
someone's gonna die in my life so that's
fine question
do they tell you the date that it's
gonna happen
sure yeah you have to full note right
it's a no yeah for sure yeah i would
rather [ __ ] know
i was kind of going that way that now i
think you're selling me on the other one
yeah
because i was like well i can it's
easier just to relive something that
i've already been through but now i'm
like
well that's the past who cares about the
past now i can plan
and then like if it is about a person
then i could spend more time with him if
it's something traumatic that's going to
happen to me like i'm going to lose both
of my legs and i can at least go like
run around
until until they're gone you know i
think because it destroys
the optimism of of like nothing bad's
gonna happen
you know like i know so eventually
something bad's gonna happen like
logically
but i can kind of live in the dark about
it and be like
no i'm just gonna ignorance nothing's
gonna happen exactly we're safe you know
and then whereas like if you confirmed
tell me like this will happen
i'm like [ __ ] now no matter it kind of
dampens every moment that i have that's
good because i know this big thing's
gonna happen
that's actually the same reason why i
would never want to know when i would
die or like how i'm gonna die or when
i'm gonna die because i'm like i don't
wanna i don't wanna
i don't want that information to hinder
me living the rest of my life and not be
present
because i'm always looking forward to
that thing that's about to happen you
don't think you
could potentially be more present
knowing
where it's going so now you're like this
day is more special now and i'm gonna
make this day a fuller day
because i know that i have only 700 days
left it's like a ticking
i don't know my life already feels like
uh a time what's it called those sand
hourglass houses like the sand going
down where i'm like
oh this shit's due or like i have to
have it done by this time and like it i
already have that mental picture and i
feel like that would make it even
worse like it would be more of a
pressure of i only have this amount of
sand left before this event happens
and i just be counting down the time
until that happens
whereas if you go back in the past it's
like kind of like bill murray's
groundhog day
where you kind of eye roll after a while
you're like yeah i know this [ __ ]
guy's gonna come up to me and tell me
this news about some [ __ ]
some stupid thing so it's like a
traumatic event yes but you're like ugh
i know then
they're gonna do this and it [ __ ]
sucks and
okay here we go i already embraced for
it because i'm and i'm already healed
from it
just like ugh you don't hold the power
over me anymore right
i just have to do it again i mean like
opposite of you i would want to know
when
and how i'm going to die because then i
can prepare like hey guys come over for
my dying party
you know no you'd have a legit ass dying
partner yeah i've never seen one
yeah after seeing your birthday right
and we're gonna have a countdown like
new year yeah
and then jean is just like love you guys
yeah so then i can be surrounded by
everyone that i love and then i get
everything that i
you know get everything situated like
all my papers and all that stuff yeah
just make it easy but then how about
that idea because i love watching a [ __ ]
ton of time traveling movies and stuff
so what about the idea that because of
you knowing this information now you
actually make that come true
so like now like it came first yeah
exactly like now it's like oh
okay you're gonna die at this time okay
cool i'm gonna have a dying party but
you didn't know that
oh you actually died because you took a
a [ __ ] shot
and you hit your head and that's how you
died at your dying party
but then if you never knew that
information you would have never had the
same time travel [ __ ] you're warping my
reality
yeah yeah we're gonna keep it simple
yeah yeah i want a dying party
i want to go to her dying party yeah all
right i think
um personally i feel like not knowing
how much time i have i feel like i kind
of waste a lot of days because i'm like
i guess i have like
40 more years so it's cool like i'll
just put off that thing until later
blah blah blah like i i guess i maybe it
would give me a fire under my ass in
order to
spend my days more wisely because i
don't know like if i'm like well i got
plenty of time like that's just kind of
how i live now i'm like well there's
plenty of time i'll do it later
oh wow wild i'm like getting getting the
fire under my ass like you've got three
years left like in my head it's always
like a
an hourglass so like i'm like i'm only
five years away from 40 and then once
i'm
40 like i should have kids because like
that's like kind of when the window
closes so like if i don't get started
now then i only have like maybe one kid
if that and then
so i i feel like everything gets
shortened and shortened and shortened to
where i'm like
i guess i gotta [ __ ] be successful
right now this instant or else i can't
or else i'll never have this thing
that's gonna happen but then if you know
that you've only got five years right
then so much other [ __ ] falls off your
plate because you don't have time for it
so it's like i don't have to do all this
[ __ ] now
i need to focus on what i'm just gonna
spend these five years with my husband
we're just gonna go to bali and we're
gonna do you know like these are how i'm
gonna spend my five years
and you didn't waste all of that time
like planning for this business and that
investment and all that stuff like you
guys just did the fun [ __ ] for five
years and then you were out
oh like you know you're going to diet
for yeah something like that you know
like maybe
if you know then you know how much money
you have to spend that's true you could
plan financially you get rid of all that
like because like because in life we
have
so much [ __ ] that we do just to kill
time and like like we have to plan for
retirement and all this other [ __ ]
but i think that's the thing is like i'm
planning for retirement
knowing that i have to be able to live x
amount of time without working
like i have to be able to live maybe 20
years after 65
and so i have to be able to pay for 20
years of not working
but if you didn't but if you're wasting
a lot of time right now getting to that
point because if you didn't have to
yeah then for those of you i knew that
then i'd be like oh okay so i could just
chill for five years
you could just hang out with steve and i
[ __ ] now give a [ __ ] and i can prepare
my family and friends
that'll make it easier for them too so
they can say bye i'm just trying to
convince you to
know that when you're i'm trying to
convince you to change your mind
i know i'm like if wouldn't it
wouldn't it relieve the pressure to know
you don't have anything else to work
like you don't have to do all that extra
[ __ ] i'd be kind of bummed
and it's like oh i guess i didn't have
it and hear me
hear me out okay i'm gonna be reckless
as [ __ ]
because i know i'm not gonna die
definitely doing like all of the
hallucinogens yeah forever
for sure yes would you do them in your
bed
look yeah somewhere safe and comfy i can
get you
[ __ ] out and know i'm not gonna die oh
you can get really choked the [ __ ] out
on my
bed on your purple mattress purple
mattress
perhaps
the opinions stayed in this episode are
not real if you look at the purple
mattress or any other affiliates
that's good
all right well as the world becomes
increasingly uncomfortable
we're all looking for as much comfort as
we can
get and the one thing that i can always
count on is how comfortable
my purple mattress is your bed is really
comfortable
yeah and i'm not just saying that
because i'm reading this paper it
literally is so comfortable you bought
that
way before we got this yeah way before
thank you purple
and uh but yeah so i need a
reimbursement please
i paid for this yeah so i've had this
mattress for many years now
and i've been so happy with it because
the purple
it's so comfortable and it also has like
this the the purple grid like
the grid and which is a stretchy
stretchy
gel material that is so supportive on
your back and your legs while cushioning
your shoulders and your neck
and your hips and and because of that
grid too it doesn't trap air
which means that air can circulate and
flow through
the entire mattress so you'll never
overheat so um
me and casey have been loving this
mattress for many many years
and uh so the grid also it bounces back
as you move
and shift oh i see why you loved it for
so many years
so many years both me and my husband
love this mattress uh so unlike memory
foam which remembers
everything that's why memory foam has
craters and divots because it doesn't
actually like
bounce back right so i freaking love it
right now you can try your purple
mattress risk
free with free shipping and returns and
financing is available too
nice purple really is comfort for an
uncomfortable world
right now you'll get 10 off any order
that's 200
or more go to purple.com big mood 10 and
use promo code big mood
10. that's purple.com 10
promo code big mood 10 for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com
bigmood10 promo code bigmood10
terms apply also you should sleep
healthy
but you should also take vitamins to
stay healthy so your pee can be a
different color
oh that's the fun part we deserve to
know what we're putting in our bodies
and why
especially when it comes to something we
take every day i started taking the
ritual vitamins because i felt kind of
sluggish during the day and then i
noticed that ever since i started taking
these vitamins
uh i feel a lot better now and i can
wake up and i can actually get some work
done i just think they're really cute
because i mean we all have to take
vitamins anyway right yeah like we all
have a multivitamin but these are the
it's like the cutest ones they're like a
little pill with like the
fish oil in it and then you could see
the little beads of the like the vitamin
minerals whatever the [ __ ] inside it's a
see-through pill it's so cute and it has
like a minty aftertaste yeah i think
they're trying to cover the fish oil
probably yeah but i like smelling it
works yeah you can smell all the
peppermint
yeah i like it ritual is the
multivitamin reimagined a multivitamin
should contain
key nutrients and forms your body can
actually use to help fill gaps in the
diet
no shady extras we know you have a gap
in your diet girl so much
so much thank you ritual
rituals delayed release capsule design
delivers high quality nutrients
including vitamin d3 in just two daily
pills
uh ritual is designed with your life
stage in mind now available for women
men and teens ritual ritual
multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages
yeah i had um i've been a member since
for like four years and i recently
switched over to the prenatal
so they have prenatal so before i was
just a young woman
and now i might have a baby
but even if you're not you should also
have prenatals if you're a woman
i heard they're good for you they are
your multivitamins are delivered to your
door every month with free shipping
always you can start snooze or cancel
your subscription anytime
and if you don't love ritual within your
first month they'll refund your first
order
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering my listeners
10 off during your first three months
visit ritual.com
big mood to start your ritual today
that's ritual.com
big mood all right we got another
question here
would you rather watch your significant
other
cheat on you yep death
death i didn't even get it all the way
out no still death violence would you
rather watch them cheat on
you with their best friend what
yes or with your best friend well i'm
his best friend
no so you know you're not included
that is accurate yeah my dudes don't
have girl best friends
okay yes oh that's fine go ahead bro oh
my god
i don't have sex with my best friend
because i don't want to see him
have sex with another dude why not no
no way i can't see that i would rather
that than
have see him have sex with one of you
guys yeah
i would rather i'm really into gayborn
so i'm like yes
please [ __ ] the dude please [ __ ] the guy
but i know that he wouldn't like he
wouldn't
it would like ruin him or something like
yeah contributing to his sexual assault
yeah i don't know i don't like i don't
yeah that's hard
whatever's easier on on him because
you're putting at your place yeah but
then it's almost like if it's a girl
then it's almost like
you better not like it though
yeah that's what i'm i don't even think
he could do it physically
i mean if he had to at this point like
yeah the situation says they have to
yeah yeah oh yeah i'd rather watch him
because i wonder and now
and then and then now i wonder how they
would answer
yeah would they be like oh i could never
sleep with your best friend i know how
steve would answer
he'd be like no [ __ ] this [ __ ] this game
yeah yeah yeah
stupid game what is this [ __ ] getting
out of this game
yeah they have it easy because girls
usually have girl best friends
so it's just watching lesbians so then
okay would you rather have sex with your
best friend or your husband's best
friend
kind of like flip it so like you have
not have sex with one of us we're not an
intimate
friend obviously for me
it would feel better to have sex with
one i don't like guys
though yeah like yeah i mean you have to
pick that's the point
yeah there's no winners in this game no
there's no winners in this game jess
okay you have one that's like would you
rather cotton candy or sugar rock candy
we can answer that i would rather cotton
candy less chewing mm-hmm
cuties actually like the rock candy how
it melts like how it pops
that one right it's those ugly [ __ ]
sticks
yeah they're rock candy oh
and then my like my crush i
shared with him because obviously i like
him but then when i took it you get the
saliva
yeah like it was so filthy those things
are all maybe that's where your
trauma started crevices of
drool in those rock candies when little
kids eat them that's just
how can you have a child with that much
saliva phobia
because like children but saliva it's
part of me
it's like my cat like he can't do
anything gross he's full on vomits and
i'm like
okay man babies have so much spit
yeah they toddlers they have a whole
period of time where it's just drool
yeah they have to wear bibs and stuff
yeah
anyways if i created it okay yeah yeah
so back to the
no winners um you got to sleep with one
of us
or with one of steve's best friends who
would you pick do you have to sleep with
one of you till you come
like when do we know it's over that's
what
i just mean that's like that's literally
a [ __ ] guy question
do i have to sleep with you until you
come oh god
that's true we bumped it really quick
that's not sex
i know okay a strap on sex
okay i'll do a scrap on sex jess can
wear a strap on and [ __ ] me
oh okay i guess gina would be more into
that yeah
yeah when it comes to women i'm the
dominant one yeah i i need to be
dominated mm-hmm
i could probably lose yeah
if they're turned around and i'm not
like in their vagina yeah okay i'll have
sex with one of you with a strap-off
oh my god steve's friends are that bad
yeah
you're making all of these [ __ ] gross
dudes in our comments so
also like frustrating me if i was like
you had to have sex with this one friend
true keep saying i
obviously i'd rather have sex with a
dude right i could even close my eyes
and he could pick one but
i out of loyalty i feel like
it'd be easier on your marriage he'd be
he'd be just as pissed if i had sex with
any of you though
one time i made out with a girl on my
birthday party but not sexually it was
just like a drunk like
we're kissing and he got really upset
that was like in our first year of
dating
so i was like i thought he would like
that because every other boyfriend's
been like whatever
girls kissing because they don't really
care about you yeah well it was just
like a
it's not sexual it was just like a it
was my one of my friends
yeah and we were just like we're drunk
make out
you know but it wasn't like a sexual
thing
i'll take one for the team for you steve
it meant nothing i promise
she means something to me we won't kiss
we'll kiss
no eye contact nothing yeah because you
would really need to write down what
other parameters like
what what concludes sex
it's true if a man's not there to come
early then yeah that's a good question i
guess it's when we come
yeah okay true when you just stop
having sex do you stop masturbating
without coming gina does
she stops having sex throughout the day
that's because you know that's a plan to
cut to finish like yeah
but that's not that's not the end of
your sex sexual experience so it doesn't
count
yeah okay penetration is normally sexual
intercourse
yes so that's what counts as sex
so just penetrate one time yeah no
does it count that i've had anal if i
just went in really quick oh my god
oh god what kind of [ __ ] question is
that
because you made it sound like it
doesn't count so now i'm like maybe i
have another it does
count so one pump counts it's true not
completion
that's like saying you're a virgin even
though he stuck it in a couple times i
don't think you're a virgin
[Laughter]
the owner of the head so if gina stuck
her strap on in me
like two times
[Applause]
apologizing to steve the whole time all
right he's just standing there watching
pissed off yeah
sorry she's like what is the scenario
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i wouldn't
it's not that gross for girls to [ __ ]
each other otherwise pumping each other
yes
stop saying the word i don't want this
image in my head
i would either be crying or laughing so
hard
or both if we were doggy
i can't even look down at you i'm just
like yeah oh my god and you wouldn't
even feel it if you had a strap-on on it
so it's easier for you than it is yeah
i just pretend it's a penis
wow just look at steve the whole time
yeah the whole time hold his hand just
hold his hand
have him put his hand on the back of my
shoulder so it feels like it yeah
he's just towering over gina
he's fully clothed yeah gina is a
two-pump chump all right
wow that's a sentence i never thought i
would hear okay
ouch first of all
it was it was forced on you it's okay
what i appreciate you though
this one oh this one i only have one
more but it's kind of i feel like we
kind of covered it in another one so i
don't know let's see um
would you rather know everything and
never be
surprised or remember
nothing and always be surprised remember
my life you can't remember anything
remember so you have amnesia no
or you know everything and nothing will
ever surprise you i already know
everything
we don't we're the opposite
like i never remember anything so much
too much my family would be so
heartbroken if i didn't remember them
that's why alzheimer's is so sad so i'd
rather not be surprised by anything
that's true
yeah i'd rather know everything because
then i finally know what that feels like
yeah oh that's okay oh it took me a
second there
i just love surprises so much but i
guess like i'd rather know everything
because yeah
alzheimer's does run in my family and it
was really sad
my grandma not knowing me that's
heartbreaking yeah
y'all are making it all sad with the
alzheimer's i was just talking about us
but that's true i guess if you don't
remember anything you don't remember
your family or anything else
yeah but then imagine how annoying like
someone keeps trying to tell you
something and you're always like i know
i know i know oh you'd have to like
temporarily like talk to humans
because you'd be like superhuman right
you know everything so you'd have like
the actu you probably never really have
a real conversation with anyone because
you know so much and then everyone else
like ants gonna come out yeah oh but you
know what the stressful thing is
you're always gonna be able to tell when
someone's lying to you it's gonna it's a
it's a double-edged sword it's good to
know but also at the same time it's like
however you have truly shitty people are
yeah that'll weed out
people that'll save us a lot of [ __ ]
time or how pure they are up here yeah
i feel bad because i was listening to a
conversation um
i can't remember who it was but they
were talking about people with really
super high iq
and just how more likely to be yeah like
they just really
they can't connect with anyone else
because like when you go i mean when you
go up like
you know 10 or something 20 iq points
compared to a lot of other people like
you just really can't communicate with
them anymore it's like they they just
feel so alone
uh you can get your mensa card and then
talk to other people that are
i guess so yeah mental people always got
to tell people they're in [ __ ]
mention no
you know what dementia means in spanish
no it means dumb girl
yes the mensa is is an acronym isn't it
yeah oh
i don't know what it is literally it
means dumb girl i swear to god hilarious
a mexican person made up this whole
thing and he's like i'm going to [ __ ]
with all of them
and nobody knew she should have called
him mental i'm a boy
or smart girl with smart girl uh
intelligent i don't know that sounds way
better
um what else uh there's another one
i always forget this one whatever you
need to practice your spanish i totally
forgot all my spanish
i remember hating saying i was in gate
classes because gate sounds so
like i'm in gate like that sounds so
weird we didn't ever call it that we're
just called gifted and talented
oh really yeah no one called it oh
everyone called it gate yeah
but yeah i'd rather i'd rather know
everything because
instead of forgetting everything because
i would rather save time yeah
like once i meet someone's like oh
you're a piece of [ __ ] i'm out you know
imagine feeling dumb everywhere like you
don't remember how to open a door yeah
so recently i met someone who had
full-blown amnesia after
um getting jumped 10 years ago
and like we were asking him um
like how far how bad was the amnesia
he's like i had to learn how to use the
bathroom again
oh my gosh it's so sad and yeah and he
it broke his mother's heart because he
didn't remember who she was he has to
relearn everything so right now it's
been 10 years so
he's technically like a 10 year old in
his mind but knows how to
you know he's only an adult he's only
had a relationship with his mom for 10
years basically basically
yeah wow okay that's so sad absolutely
heartbreaking what if we changed it a
little bit to like you
you won't forget like how to pee or open
the door but you just like don't forget
like things you learn at school like you
don't remember like things you learn at
school or just like common sense [ __ ] or
whatever so it's not like your
basic human function's still there yeah
like basic human function function is
still there and like you know your
friends and family but you just can't
learn anything new or like remember
stories people told you
or stuff like that still you just my
life is beautiful because i can remember
everything yeah that's
true so even all the traumas and
everything in that even if like
even if that would suck to be to know
everything and never have surprises
again
i think it would suck more to not
remember anything oh thank god that
means we never have to plan a surprise
party for any of you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's like oh because we have them so
yeah we don't have surprises
i'm complaining about something that
doesn't happen i wanted a surprise party
so bad when i was a kid
but no one would throw me one so i tried
to plan my own surprise
how did you do that i just tried to hit
really hard that i wanted a surprise
party and then my mom just throw me a
regular party like tell me about it
well i can't complain about that
she's a big nerd i was a nerd i just
because they show it in every tv show
every
tv show ever has had a surprise party
you're not special unless someone throws
you one i don't think i've ever gotten
one and then someone
she comes in talking [ __ ] about people
that are at the party
oh yeah and they're all there and you
wanted that to happen
no all right guys well our hour's up
now but um thank you for watching and i
hope you enjoyed these would you rather
tell us if you want us to keep doing
these if you're like that was enough uh
you don't have to do that anymore or if
you're like yes please
these are fun let us know leave your
answers how do you feel about it yeah
leave your answers i want to know
like how much of the world thinks like
us or what do we miss
in the kissing or blow jobs during the
realm kissing your bloodshed
or your own suggestions which would you
rather do you want us to answer
oh yeah oh yeah it's kind of hard to
find like good questions because if you
go online and look and look for you need
to be very profound they're usually kind
of stupid
intellectually here's what i'm going to
do i'm going to go into the comments i'm
going to leave two comments
team [ __ ] and team p whoever gets the
most votes so dumb
team p anyways but
no team p but in a slushie okay gross
all right
[Laughter]
all right you guys if you really want to
support the show visit our sponsors
also leave a comment like all that good
stuff subscribe share with your friends
anyways thank you and we'll see you next
time team come